(Musique film d'horreur)
Alors, Lucien Burnoud…
vous êtes donc né le 18 mars 1948.
mort le 24 juin 1962.
Niveau fantôme novice.
Vous êtes donc sur le point de passer
votre diplôme d’esprit frappeur
et d’accéder au rang
de fantôme standard,
Alors êtes-vous prêt
à passer cet examen?
Oui Monsieur.
Très bien. Alors vous allez donc chasser
hors de l’hôtel votre premier client,
celui de la chambre 407.
Alors quelle sera votre
technique d’approche?
Moi je te conseille
de lui voler ses chaussettes.
Les vivants ils aiment pas trop
qu’on leur vole leurs chaussettes.
Non, Ernest,
qu’est-ce que tu fous là?
Ben je lui donne des conseils quoi,
pour pas qu’il se foire.
Ouais Ernest casse toi
franchement t’es relou là.
Mais non, mais
je peux le guider le petit,
je suis un fantôme de niveau 4 quand même.
- Non Ernest…
déconne pas avec ça,
on sait que t’es fantôme de merde.
Non, c’est ton rang
et ça existe Ernest.
Oh, je te rappelle
que t’as raté trois fois ton examen,
Voilà t’es tellement à chier
qu’on la inventé pour toi
ce rang de fantôme de merde,
t’en souviens-tu?
Laissez moi repasser l’examen.
-Non.
Non. T’as eu ta chance trois fois Ernest,
c’est non.
L’écoute pas.
Moi je te dis tu lui voles ses chauss...
Barre toi Ernest,
j’ai un examen à passer là.
Tu fais chier.
Bon Lucien…
Prêt à chasser votre
premier client de l’hôtel?
Oui Monsieur.
Putain d’hôtel de merde!
Bonjour
-Bonjour Madame.
Normalement j’ai une chambre
au nom de Ménard
Vous êtes dans la 403.
Votre clef.
-Merci
Bonjour, alors je voudrais…
-Attendez une minutes je reviens.
Bonjour, je voudrais une chambre
près de la 403 s’il-vous-plait.
Vous me voyez là?
- Oui…
J’aimerais une chambre
près de la 403.
Vous, vous êtes vivant?
-Oui, je suis vivant. J’aimerais une chambre près...
... Et vous me voyez?
- Oui, et je comprends pas là, il se passe quoi?
Qu’est-ce que je peux faire pour vous?
J’aimerais une chambre près de la 403,
c’est pas compliqué.
J’ai pas de chambre près de la 403.
-Ah merde.
Il y a la 407 qui est libre.
Ah voilà,
ben je vais prendre ça.
Pardon?
-La 407. Je vais vous prendre la 407.
Monsieur, je viens de vous dire
que j’avais pas de …
La 407 est libre.
- Ben oui,
c’est votre collègue qui vient de le dire.
- Non, non chut. Je suis pas là.
A règler en quittant l'hôtel
D’accord. Et c’est combien...?
C’est ultra cher, d’accord.
Bienvenue à Montreux, Monsieur.
Ah putain.
Eh Clara,
qu’est-ce que tu fais à Montreux?
Eh Clara, qu’est-ce que tu fais à Montreux?
Eh, toi aussi t’es à Montreux?
Moi je suis là pour le festival.
-Félix ?
Eh Montreux qu’est-ce que tu fais à Cla…
- Qu’est-ce que tu fais en Suisse?
Ben écoute j’allais te poser la même question,
qu’est-ce que tu fais là,
c’est trop bizarre de te voir là.
Moi je suis là pour le
Montreux Comédie Festival.
Est-ce que t’as vu sur Facebook
que j’allais au festival
et tu m’as suivie?
Tu sais que je commence à en avoir marre
de tes combines de merde.
Tu peux pas faire comme tout le monde et …
-Wow wow wow,
eh Clara. Wow, coup de pression là, eh.
C’est une coïncidence,
c'est tout
Tu peux pas accepter pour une fois que le destin …
-Ben, Clara?
Gustave!
- Ca va?
T’es dans le même hôtel!
"Nice"
Felix, Gustave,
un ami de travail.
Gustave, lui c’est Félix.
Euh, Félix,
c’est pas ton ex un peu chelou là?
Salut mec!
Et donc euh, ça va mieux toi?
Mais oui ça va,
pourquoi tu poses la question?
Je suis ultra actif en ce moment,
euh, je fais de la muscu,
je prends soin de moi, je lis pas mal de livres.
Ben mec.
-Tiens c’est lui.
Du coup, on est tous au festival,
on pourrait peut-être se faire un truc
tous ensemble, genre un spectacle.
Ben écoute,
je sais pas encore mais …
Moi ça va être short niveau timing.
Non mais on peut se faire un dej,
genre demain, non?
Carrément.
Eh mais y’a pas de…
-Non mais arrêtez oh!
Quoi?
-Non mais ils sont relou aussi …
De qui tu parles?
-Ben eux là.
On peut parler tranquilles, messieurs,
je peux parler tranquille?
Quoi?
- Qui ?
Hein?
Quoi: «hein»?
De quoi tu parles?
-Il est con?
De qui tu parles?
-Eux.
Mais qui «eux»?
-Nous.
Bon euh,
faut que j’aille chercher un euh…
SalutGustave …
On se voit vite hein!
Non mais vous êtes sérieux là ?
On fait pas ça aux gens.
Ah, c’est bien cette phrase aussi.
-Redis-le?
On fait pas ça aux gens!
Laissez moi tranquille.
-Ca faudrait que, ça c’est bien aussi.
Laissez moi putain!
Ok, tenez vous prêts
il est là.
Non mais sérieux, c’est quoi ce pays,
on est où là?
Il parle tout seul.
Ok, donc vous avez tous décidé de me faire chier
dans cet hôtel, c’est ça?
Ok, on y va dans 3, 2, 1 …
Il flippe. Le mec flippe!
Eh les gars, y’a Ernest qu’essaye de faire peur
à la meuf du 4ème. Venez!
Non mais il est nul, il est nul,
on va arrêter d’en faire tout un cake!
Ouais. Mais elle est à poil.
-Oh...
Allez, go!
(Hurlement)
Bon il est où le mec,
le grand là,
qui est moins pale que vous?
Bof, je sais pas, à cette heure là
il est parti glander.
Bon, ce que vous allez faire,
c’est que vous allez lui donner ce chèque.
Non, non, non,
attendez, attendez.
Déjà je peux  pas lui donner
parce que je suis concrètement …
Vous êtes mort, c’est ça?
-Oui, voilà.
Du coup, j’ai peut-être un
petit service à vous demander.
Quoi?
Vous avez remarqué que l’hôtel
est plein de fantômes hein.
Oui, oui
Dont je suis le coordinateur.
Ce que je vous demande,
c’est de rentrer dans votre chambre,
vous attendez sagement Ernest,
qui est un fantôme
qu’on pourrait qualifier de nul, nul à chier.
Euh, il fait peur à personne.
Vous faites semblant d’avoir peur,
vous flippez votre race,
et vous déguerpissez quoi.
Donc, ce que vous voulez que je fasse
c’est prendre une chambre pour la nuit,
Ouais...
Ne pas dormir dedans,
et en plus faut que je la paye cette chambre, c’est ça?
Non, pour ça je peux m’arranger
pour qu’elle soit payée.
Vraiment?
-Ouais.
Donc, en gros,
j’aurais une chambre gratuite quoi.
Oui. Et service VOD.
Et avec, euh,
avec les chaines pour adulte?
Et les chaines porno!
Vous partez monsieur?
Non je, non je reste.
Ah ben je vois que vous avez pris la …
Hum
je vois que Monsieur est un gros porc.
Allez, tu peux le faire champion,
tu peux le faire.
Ah, il est dans la salle de bain.
Ok, étape 1: analyser la victime.
Ok, un mec pas très costaud, un peu moche.
Ok, victime facile.
Etape 2: premiers frissons.
Ah, la buée, c’est bien ça,
je vais lui faire le coup de la buée.
T’es sérieux? «Buée»?
T’as écrit «buée» sur la buée?
Ben je sais pas,
je m’étais dis que ça serait flip…
T’es le mec qui nous voit,
c’est ça?
Oui, mais c’est pas ça.
Tu peux pas écrire «buée» sur la buée.
T’es sérieux là?
Tu peux pas écrire «buée» sur la buée
en espérant me faire peur.
Tu dois écrire un truc genre
«derrière toi»
ou «je te vois».
Ouais, «je te vois, je te vois»,
c’est vachement bien ça «je te vois».
Oui, mais «je te vois» avec un S
pas avec un X, c’est pas la voix,
et puis écrit pas tout doux
comme ça,
écris genre en mode euh «ça va pas bien»
- Genre saccadé?
Voilà, c’est ça.
C’est vachement bien ça,
je vais le tester dans une autre chambre.
Non mais je vous vois,
je suis le mec qui peut vous voir.
Ah ok.
(Crie étouffé)
Ca a marché, ça a marché.
Il a crié et tout!
Ah, t’as réussi
à chasser un client de l’hôtel?
Non, non il a juste crié
mais moi j’ai jamais fait crier quelqu’un avant.
Vas y, donne moi d’autres trucs,
je vais faire peur à quelqu’un d’autre.
Non, sérieux, je …
Attends …
Je sais à qui on pourrait faire peur.
Bon, en gros depuis "Psychose",
ce qui nous fait peur c’est les douches.
Donc t’hésites pas,
tu le malmènes tu vois.
Ouais, et si je touche son kiki?
Je pense que c’est un risque
que tu dois prendre.
Qu’est-ce que c’est?
Aahh!!! Aaaahhh!!
Alors? Ca va?
T’as touché sa bite?
Un peu, ouais c’était marrant.
Donc, maintenant ce que tu peux lui faire
c’est genre un petit rire d’enfant
Non un rire de clown.
Fais lui un rire de clown. C’est bien ça.
Et ça fait peurça les clowns?
Ouais. Depuis «ça»
on a tous peur des clowns, tous.
Depuis quoi?
-«Ca»
Okay…
- Tu te mets derrière lui, tu vois,
près de son oreille comme ça
et tu fais un petit rire comme ça, tu fais:
(Rire Flippant)
Try it !
(Rire Nul)
C’est de la merde. Donc du coup ce qu’on va faire
c’est que tu vas parler à l’envers.
Ouais d’accord,
genre du latin.
(en chantant): On s’est regardées,
puis elle m’a touchée …
(essaye de parler «à l’envers»
mais s’étouffe)
(continuant la chanson)
… La bite.
J’ai pas réussi, j’ai toussé.
hum, je sais ce que tu peux faire!
- Euh, pas un truc trop hardcore.
pour faire peut des fois,
faut faire des trucs hardcore.
(Bruit de chasse d'eau)
(Hurlement)
(En riant)
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Qu’est-ce que vous faites?
Pardon?
- Ben euh,
on fait une caméra cachée là
pour hum, pour Internet.
Pour Internet?
Vous les jeunes
vous êtes vraiment des gros cons.
Ok, et t’y vas comme un bourrin,
tu le malmènes ce connard.
Vas y, vas y
Quand j’ai rejoint la société,
je me suis dit,
ils vont avoir besoin d’éléments forts.
Et je me suis dit que
Gauthier pourrait …
… Excuse moi.
Gauthier il a vu que le DRH…
Ouais euh, je disais quoi?
Ouais, euh,
quand il est rentré dans la société …
Qu’est-ce que c’est ces putains,
c’est chiant, merde!
Qu’est-ce que …?
C’est pas moi!
Non je te jure c’est pas moi!
Reviens c’est pas moi!
Bien joué, bien joué,
bien joué!
Ok, maintenant qu’il est hors jeu,
on passe à l’étape 2 du plan.
En gros, ce que tu vas faire …
Yannick ?
téma le gars.
(Musique Suspense)
Allo oui, passez moi le conseil des fantômes
s’il vous plait.
(cri)
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe Clara?
Je t’ai entendue crier
et puis ta porte
elle était complètement ouverte.
Oh mon dieu!
T’inquiètes pas.
Démon! Arrête tes tourments
et laisse Clara en paix!
Calme ta rage et oriente la
vers une activité un peu plus constructive.
Merci, créature impure.
Maintenant, sors.
Mais comment t’as fait ça?
Normalement ça devrait plus arriver
mais si ça re-arrive,
tu m’appelles.
Je suis dans la chambre 407.
Oui?
Ca te dirait qu’on
mange ensemble ce soir?
Tu sais
j’ai pas mal de choses à faire,
j’ai mon entrainement de … psychique
et ma muscu un peu à faire
Mais je vais trouver
un petit créneau pour toi.
Alors, ça a marché?
Oui!
On mange ensemble ce soir!
Ah, bravo mec!
(rires)
Et du coup,
et ce soir tu pourras m’aider hein,
on pourra faire un petit truc
bien sympa tous les deux.
Ah ouais non,
en fait je me disais
comme je me sens prêt
à repasser le diplôme,
je voulais m’entrainer ce soir
sur des vrais clients.
Oh mais non, s’il te plait,
s’il te plait
une toute dernière fois,
Bon d’accord, allez.
Toi et moi,
ce soir on va envoyer du méga pâté.
Du quoi?
Eh Nestor tu sais pas où
je pourrais trouver du méga...
Ah pardon
C’est le conseil, ils sont d’accord
pour que tu repasses ton diplôme, demain.
C’est vrai?
J’ai du lécher pas mal de cul
mais bon,
ils sont ok, ils sont ok,
Oh, c’est chouette!
Et c’est quelle chambre qu’il faut chasser?
Oui très bien, merci.
La 407.
De quoi? La 407?
Mais c’est la chambre de Felix.
Ah ton…? Ah oui ah merde,
c’est con ça.
Je peux pas chasser Felix,
il peut nous voir.
Oui mais bon, étant donné
la difficulté de la mission,
ils ont dit que tu pourrais directement accéder
au rang de fantôme de style.
Quoi?
Pas fantôme standard,
directement fantôme de style?
Fantôme de style, direct.
Non, je, je peux pas faire ça.
Ecoute Ernest, depuis la nuit des temps,
les morts font peur aux vivants.
Lui il est vivant, alors il peut nous voir,
il peut pas nous voir ...
Tu t’en branles,
ça reste un vivant.
Tu lui fais peur, voilà,
fin de mission, fantôme de style.
Ben non mais
c’est un peu mon ami maintenant.
Ben écoute, c’est lui...
ou c’est nous.
Et du coup,
depuis que je suis dans cet hôtel,
j’ai des dons de télékinésie
et d’hydrothérapie.
D’hydrothérapie?
Ouais bébé, tu veux plus de vin?
Wow !
Et encore, t’as rien vu.
Incroyable.
-Ecoute, je vais aller faire pipi.
Mais toi ne bouge surtout pas.
Ecoute, je sais que t’es en rendez vous
mais je tenais à m’excuser
Je sais pas ce qui m’est arrivé,
c'était pas moi.
Je pense sincèrement
que...
que l’hôtel est hanté.
Non, t’inquiètes pas,
c’est encore un coup de Félix.
Comment ça,
encore un coup de Felix?
Félix il a toujours été comme ça.
Je sais pas comment il fait
parce que c’est vraiment convaincant
mais il fait ce genre de trucs.
Quand on était ensemble,
on ne se voyait pas pendant des semaines,
il se laissait pousser la barbe,
il revenait
et il me faisait croire qu’il venait du futur
et qu’il fallait que je couche
d’avantage avec lui
parce que sinon
notre famille allait être en danger
Ok...
mais vous êtes toujours ensemble?
Non.
Parce que moi je veux pas
me mettre en travers d'une relation …
Ah non,non, non.
Tu ne te mets en travers de rien du tout.
Ok, parce que j’ai...
j’aime bien passer du temps avec toi et …
‘Fin je t’aime bien quoi,
et c’est pour ça …
Moi aussi je t’aime bien.
Ben on se voit demain?
-Ca marche.
Dis moi Clara,
est-ce que tu veux me voir voler?
J’ai un truc à te dire.
En fait le conseil a accepté
que je repasse mon examen.
Sérieux? C’est cool ça!
Ouais, c’est cool sauf que…
C’est toi
que je dois chasser en fait.
Ah, c’est moins bien.
Ah mais du coup
tu vas pas accepter?
Qu’est-ce qu’on va faire?
Ben, je me disais
peut être on pourrait faire semblant quoi,
je sais pas,
je rentre dans ta chambre
et tu te mets à crier
et tu quittes l’hôtel.
Ouais, non c’est pas mal
mais ouais non c’est mort
parce que je suis bien ici donc euh …
Je sais mais euh,
‘fin je sais pas, tu peux faire ça pour moi
juste un service, un seul.
Non mais je sais, je sais et merci,
franchement, sérieux c’était trop cool,
Mais Clara et moi tu vois,
on se retrouve enfin, c’est cool
Ecoute euh,
Clara elle veut pas de toi.
Ah mais d’accord
En fait tu dis ça pour me vener
et du coup je me barre de l’hôtel.
Non mais tout le monde est pas à faire
des petits stratagèmes là
pour arriver à ses fins comme toi,
je te dis la vérité là.
Mais non tu dis ça,
ah tu dis ça parce que t’es jaloux.
Tu dis ça parce que t’es jaloux, OK.
Mais jaloux de quoi?
T’as rien.
T’es jaloux parce que moi je suis vivant
et je peux encore baiser
et toi t’as le seum parce que t’es mort
et du coup tu peux plus baiser.
N’importe quoi et de toute façon
j’ai jamais baisé, même de mon vivant.
Tu vois,
ça ça m’étonne pas par exemple.
Ah ouais? Et ben tu sais quoi,
je vais le passer l’examen,
et prépare toi
à bien chier dans ton froc.
Ouais, ouais d’accord ben Ok,
vas y, essaye de me faire peur,
essaye un peu de me faire peur
espèce de fantôme de merde.
Ouais, c’est ça, crève!
Non, non, non crève pas tiens d’ailleurs,
reste bien vivant, comme ça on se croisera plus jamais,
j’espère que tu vas avoir une belle vie,
une longue et belle vie!
Et ben j’espère que je vais jamais mourir,
j’espère que je vais rester vivant longtemps!
Nestor !
appelle le conseil
et dis leur que je serais présent à l’examen.
Et dis leur de prendre
de quoi nettoyer la chambre.
Parce que la 407
elle va être pleine de caca.
Parce qu’il va se chier dessus
tellement il aura peur!
Standard des fantômes j’écoute?
Oui, passez moi
le conseil des fantômes, s’il vous plait.
Ben t’es là toi?
-Ouais, je suis stagiaire du conseil maintenant.
Alors Ernest Desfeuilles.
Né le 23 septembre 1940
et mort le 15 mars 1964.
Vous êtes sur le point
de passer votre diplôme d’esprit frappeur
et d’accéder au rang
de fantôme de style,
êtes-vous donc prêt
à passer cet examen?
Ouais.
Vous allez donc chasser
votre premier client de l’hôtel.
Celui de la chambre 407.
Quelle sera votre approche?
Je sais ce qui lui fait peur.
Bon. Faut y aller là?
J’y arrive pas.
-Pardon?
J’y arrive pas,
je peux pas le faire.
Très bien Ernest.
4ème échec, ouh.
Tu viens à l’instant
d’être relégué
au rang de sous merde. Bien.
Tu sais quoi?
Vas te faire foutre.
Sous-sous-merde, bravo!
C’est bien ça,
ça vient d’être inventé.
Sous-sous-merde,
allez!
Non mais je peu vous voir.
-On sait
on prend juste ce fauteuil
pour s’en faire un lit.
Ok.
Désolée mais on dort
vraiment trop mal ici.
Qu’est-ce que t’as,
ça va pas?
Non mais je pensais que
c’était Ernest c'est tout.
Ah ouais, Ernest.
Vous avez rompu, c’est ça?
Quoi? Non, on n’a pas rompu,
on n’est pas ensemble. On n’est pas gay.
Oh oh, c’est pas grave d’être PD
Ce qui est grave dans l’histoire là en gros,
c’est de baiser avec un mort.
Ca c’est chaud par contre.
on n’a pas baisé,
on n’a jamais baisé déjà,
on n’est pas ensemble,
on n’est pas homosexuels.
Je suis pas homosexuel,
j’ai une meuf,
d’ailleurs c’est la meuf d’en face.
403?
-Oui, voilà.
Oui, ben la 403 je l’ai vue rentrer
dans sa chambre avec un autre mec.
Quoi?
Un grand?
Et tu faisais quoi,
t’étais en train de les chasser?
Ben non, ils étaient trop mignons,
on chasse pas les gens trop mignons ici.
Eh, je sais. Toi et moi,
on va faire un plan ensemble.
On a qu’à dire que t’es ma nouvelle meuf
, tu vois,
mais genre t’as bu un truc
qui te rend invisible...
Oh oh oh, ce genre de petit plan à la merde
c’est pas pour moi ça.
Faut que tu sois honnête,
c’est ça qui marche en fait.
Tu vas la voir,
tu la regardes dans les yeux, tu lui dis:
«je suis PD, je suce, j’aime ça,
ça m’est tombé dessus, c’est comme ça»
Mais je suis pas PD,
on n’est pas PD,
Ernest et moi
on est juste des amis.
Mais tu vois Ernest
pour nous ici c’est le petit frère.
Alors qu’en fait
c’est le plus vieux.
Et jamais
il aurait abandonné son diplôme.
Pour personne.
Il a abandonné?
Ouais.
Donc fais pas ton gros PD,
et va lui dire que tu l’aimes.
D’accord, oui, ok.
Ok
Si ça peut te rassurer,
le gars qui est avec 403,
il a un tout petit zizi.
Alors que le tien il est beau.
Quoi?
(Musique douce)
Donc euh, t’as le droit
de sortir de l’hôtel comme ça?
Je fais ce que je veux,
je suis un fantôme.
Ecoute euh, je suis vraiment désolé
pour ce que je t’ai dit.
Je le pensais pas
et justement je pense que t’es un,
t’es un bon fantôme.
Et t’avais raison sur Clara,
du coup je l’ai laissée partir.
Je tenais à m’excuser.
C’est un peu long à expliquer
mais j’ai pas de super pouvoirs.
Si je t’ai menti pendant aussi longtemps,
c’est parce que j’avais peur de te perdre.
Je me disais qu’il fallait
que je fasse des trucs de ouf
pour te garder quoi.
Je tiens à m’excuser de ça.
Salut.
Attends Felix,
comment t’as fait
pour faire léviter mon lit?
C’est parce que
je peux voir les morts. Salut.
Donc euh,
c’est vraiment fini, fini?
Oui.
Et apparemment Gustave
il a un petit zizi.
Ouais je sais, je l’ai touché.
Et j’ai bien réfléchi, je vais partir de l’hôtel
en criant ma race,
comme ça tu pourras dire à tout le monde
que tu m’as fait peur.
C’est gentil mais c’est trop tard.
Ils ont annulés mon examen.
Du coup je suis relégué
au rang de sous-sous-merde.
Et c’est un rang permanent.
Donc même si t’arrivais à chasser quelqu’un,
tu resterais une sous-sous-merde?
Ouais.
Donc en gros,
il faudrait que tu fasses quelque chose
de vraiment, vraiment très très gros,
c’est ça?
Ouais...
J’ai une idée.
T’es prêt?
Ouais.
Ok, c’est parti.
Oh mon dieu, oh mon dieu,  !
aidez moi, aidez moi,
aidez moi !
A l’aide!
Aidez moi, l’hôtel est hanté,
il y a un fantôme!
Oh non, pas lui
Bon, ne vous inquiétez pas
tout le monde,
ce jeune con
fait une caméra cachée.
Pour Internet.
- Ok, ok. Go, go, go!
Oh mon dieu,
mais qu’est-ce qui m’arrive,
Oh la la, oh mais qu’est-ce qui
se passe pour moi?
Putain t’es lourd.
Ils ont des câbles,
c’est pour Internet je vous ai dit.
Ok, Plan B !
Ouais.
Ah! Nooonn!!
Ne paniquez pas,
ne leur donner pas cette satisfaction,
ils veulent juste faire le buzz!
Merde.
Ok, plan C
-T’es sur?
Des fois pour faire peur,
faut faire des trucs hardcore.
Ah ben qu’est-ce qui m’arrive?
Oh mon dieu!
Surtout pas, non!
Me violez pas Monsieur le Fantôme!
Pas dans les fesses!
NOOOOOONNNNN !
(Musique épique)
On est d’accord
qu’on en parle jamais de ça, hein?
On dira qu’ils sont partis
dès que tu me tirais les pieds.
Ouais,
enfin on verra
Non, on verra pas
Ecoute,
je suis fier de toi et de ton pote.
Le conseil a appelé
et ils ont fait de toi un …
(Chuchotements)
De quoi?
Ils ont fait de toi
un fantôme de style.
Hein, attends j’ai,
un fantôme de quoi?
Un fantôme de style.
Un fantôme de style,
avec du style, quoi.
moi je suis un fantôme de style?
Ernest, fantôme de style.
Monsieur?
-Bonjour, je viens régler ma chambre s’il vous plait.
Oui, très bien.
Ca fait donc 5 nuits,
ça fait bien mal au cul … Ah
Non, apparemment
ça a déjà été payé Monsieur.
Merci.
Comment ça merci?
Non pas toi,
toi ta gueule.
Eh, euh …
Poignée de main d’homme?
Regarde putain là, là!
Tu vois, là!
Tu vas me manquer Felix
Je suis pas fou.
Oui ben c’est deux mecs
qui se font un câlin, c’est pas …
Non!
Que dalle !
Fantôme de Merde !
- Quoi ?
Ca va là ?